y esto sigue empeorando progresivamente,
o progresando.
Si estuvieran dentro del 1%, me imagino que estarían contentos.
(Risas)
Lo que esto me enseña
es que es mucho más fácil poder escuchar música.
La gente dispone de más música que nunca,
y, sin embargo, escogen escuchar la misma música de siempre.
Lo cual es una pena.
Inspirado por el amor a la investigación, desentierro y conservación de la música
creé un sitio web llamado "Music is My Sanctuary" en 2007.
Nuestro eslogan siempre ha sido, "Futuros clásicos y tesoros olvidados".
Este muestra nuestro amor por descubrir la música
e introducir música vieja y nueva.
Desde un humilde comienzo,
hemos construido una plataforma mundial con una audiencia masiva
y con más de 100 colaboradores.
Hemos creado más de 10 000 artículos de contenido,
más de 500 horas de contenido de audio.
Nuestro público son personas
que sólo quieren más de lo que les ofrecen
los canales de música convencionales.
Quieren hacerlo,
quieren excavar más profundo,
pero no tienen las 20 horas semanales que tenemos nosotros los nerds,
por lo tanto confían que lo hagamos por ellos.
La conservación es central a todo lo que hacemos.
Creemos en recomendaciones humanas más que en algoritmos.
Podría hablar de mi pasión por desenterrar discos durante días,
pero déjenme terminar de esta manera.
Después de hacerlo durante muchos años,
la colección de discos de un coleccionista
se convierte en su autobiografía.
El año pasado estaba trabajando de DJ en Polonia,
y mis anfitriones
tenían una increible colección de discos
y por supuesto me intrigó
y les pregunté si los vendían.
Me explicaron que esa era la colección
de su querido amigo Maceo, que había muerto hace unos meses.
Y estaban haciendo un proyecto donde invitaban a diferentes personas
para tomar la colección y crear algo nuevo con ella,
por ejemplo, haciendo muestras o mezclas de DJ,
para darle una nueva vida.
Así que después de unas horas de explorar la colección
y de crear una mezcla de DJ,
aunque no lo había conocido antes
lo sentí de una manera especial,
él y yo
hablamos sobre discos durante varias horas.
Como desenterradores de discos,
nuestra labor y nuestras colecciones de discos están
para ser pasadas a la próxima generación.
El arte bello merece ser apreciado, ser compartido y ser redescubierto.
Abracen a los conservadores;
somos la alternativa a los canales de música convencionales,
sean digitales o no.
Vayan más allá del algoritmo.
Cualquiera que sea la música que les guste,
hay tantos sitios web, programas de radio, DJs y tiendas de discos
esperando poder compartir sus descubrimientos con Uds.
Hacemos ese trabajo por Uds.
Todo lo que tienen que hacer es abrir los oídos y correr riesgos.
La música les va a cambiar la vida.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)